let's make way for Emmanuel Sanders the
49ers wide receiver
Niners with that great victory over the
Saints over the weekend and Emmanuel
Sanders joining us now how low and loud
was it in that building man it was loud
it was loud you know uh you know after
the game you know went on my Instagram
and I posted and I said I told the fans
pretty much that you know how great of a
winner was in that hostile environment
because it was hostile there I mean
those fans they came they understood the
magnitude of the game and they
definitely came and was screaming loud
as they possibly can and it gets very
very loud at that stadium but I tell you
what man we got a lot of guys of
resilience no matter how loud it gets
you know like we're just there to do our
job and I feel like that's the reason
why we got outstanding because it was
loud but like I never at one point on
the side I was like oh this is too loud
for us or this is loud like but after
the game you go back you say man it was
laughing I could clearly like a cow he
literally had to take a knee so we can
like all like bundle up just so we can
hear Jimmy but we ended up making it
happen which was smart on college for
that take me back to that fourth and -
Cole what's it like in the huddle yeah
oh really it was just like I look let's
see if we can convert it there was
really no pressure to it it was like
let's see if we can convert it
oh then I see if we think we can drive
down here you know they came out here
playing this man-to-man all across the
board was a two and I was just like I
was like man we got exploit this and I
know college thing this eighteen-inch
hours a week we gotta go out and exploit
it let me try to get one of our guys
open hopefully you know break a tackle
and get down the sideline and get a fill
go rage so we're able to do that
did you realize what George kettle had
pulled off there on that play uh at
first uh would arrest to the flags I
want to know who's who
facematch who and then once I found out
that it was the Saints that did it
you know I definitely was happy but I
was like you know what like let's get on
just game still because I've been a part
of a lot of games where it's like it's
not over until the clock strikes zero
and so that was the only thing on what
mile was like communicating with the
running back so let's let's take care of
the football
of and now that like I was happy when
Kyle you know good picture like a tree
formation even though that we couldn't
ran the ball again kind of creepy
formation let Robbie come on is just
kick the field goal and that felt good
if your ball go through that who is the
best team you faced this year we are the
Saints and Baltimore for sure
man oh shoot games are really good you
know obviously how we'll be playing both
of those teams game but you know
definitely it was a battle it's a battle
out there for us oh those teams brought
it for sure but you watch Lamar Jackson
from the sidelines what's that like you
don't have to I'm trying to stop the guy
Jesus seems to drive just do crazy stuff
you know and the most annoying part is
he's the quarterback running around like
somebody's hitting through scared it to
do something strike him down but it
never have acute chugging away babes and
impressive player talking Emmanuel
Sanders the Niners wide receiver they
got the Falcons coming up next
where's your Super Bowl ring jewelry box
you bring it out I really bring it out I
really bring it out it's like I have
family over they want to see it but I
out there the query so big man is it way
too much
weird happy next thing you know like I
gotta take like 100 to 150 pictures oh
my god like if I you know that out
I just gotta leave it there sometimes I
open the box and look at it like man I
needed other words and the truth we the
ring is though but I think it's just it
the experiences and the the memories
that I have that are all collected in
that one ring that I look at it every
member you know so that's what we're
trying to do here what is that one
memory that you have winning that Super
Bowl with the Steelers I remember right
on the field it was a lot of people in
my face a lot of cameras in my face but
I remember looking for my son look all I
said oh it's just one hold my son and
get it and get pictures of me on to my
son when in a sewer walls and be able to
spend time with them on the field with a
fall there you think you're really just
take it in another memory I have is also
afraid and I was on just a fun date
truthfully I didn't know what to expect
oh so it was one of those things where I
was just kind of like blown away but if
I get another opportunity had a brain
dump you're going to take it all this do
uh I don't know if you have a chip on
your shoulder I think there were six
wide receivers who went ahead of you in
the draft you do you have a chip on your
shoulder did you have a chip on your
shoulder because of that I think all my
shoulders case you know I was weak Oh
sometimes I feel like I won't get the
recognition I deserve but you know that
happens you know and so it could be his
you know how far as a 49ers organization
they're having success now Keibler or
you know able to see my talent is really
kind of a couple people going back on a
word so what they say no and so here I
am a 32 year old receiver you know I was
I was in there and we were losing
they're saying oh he's 32 he's old
time to move on from his guy you know
this and that and it's bad just because
we were losing they just won't find a
way to point a finger at somebody or
something so now here I am at 32 and I'm
still going in and
I'm still taking plant you know so I'm
just you know happy to be in this
situation that I mean it hopefully I
just continuously make the most of it
I thought you were going to the Patriots
did you think you were going to the
Patriots I didn't think so
but you know it was one of those things
where possibly could have but I knew was
a lot of teams even the Saints Lucinda
and in the talks of trying to get so I
knew I knows a lot of the props is Jimmy
Garoppolo funny in the huddle was the
old business school quarterbacks I play
with besides Bateman he's very cool
they're very gay he doesn't have the ego
but now yeah he works his butt up
it's young guy it's young guy who like I
know a lot of people were expecting him
you know or tell him about greatness but
Timmy wants to be great but at the same
time he's not putting pressure on
himself to be great being himself I
think that's what I love about it like
like you can see he's just a genuine
human being but he's not trying to
portray some image or pieces out by a
knife being himself and in doing that he
stabbed a lot of success really he's
going to keep going up exactly to tell
the foundation that he's built upon it
is strong and so good at the 49ers or
I'd like to have a guy like that at the
court they go what was it like being in
a huddle the first time with Peyton
Manning practice well and I guess in a
game like like the first experience
you're like you know this would be the
story that you would tell your kids
about Peyton Manning me my first game
with Jamie was a preseason game and I
remember after he was doing in Denver I
had like walking to and I won go playing
at their appreciating game my first game
as a Bronco was going to be an opening
game and I got a text from Peyton the
night before in it you know he wants to
get to work with me he wants to get
somewhere
neither of the trainer's was like that
you should play and phases like I want
to get some work with you if you can go
out and you can play whatever we can
have or we can have all really dis
recovery just go out and play a half for
me and we'll go from there so you know I
walked into the trainer on my own planet
like you know I'm playing I gotta get to
work
Sycho it I go out and loo you have in
you know in the first half I have like I
think like a hundred yards and
appreciate I have like a hundred yards
one of the first passes I call from or
maybe the second or third was like a 65
yard bomb touchdown and then I come back
like a minute and a half later after we
get the ball back and catch like a
35-yard touchdown and I had a hundred
yards and two touchdowns and a half an
appreciating game I was like what the
hey did you ever get an autograph from
Peyton no I never got an autograph
that's my guy talk to well I talked to
Austin oh so I don't think I need that
no but like a jersey do you like jerseys
I should though at some point I'll
probably go around all the explains I
play ready to set them my whole bunch of
Jesus in them send them to the you know
be able to get they jerseys and whatnot
but I haven't got experience yeah yeah I
collect them for your son you know one
day just say those are the guys that dad
played with hey congrats on the season
and you know we look forward to seeing
you in the playoff we appreciate the
time for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on be our live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]